[Música]
y en teme a los humanos digitales
y por qué habríamos de temer a los
humanos digitales
en la primera revolución digital aquella
que nos trajo internet a nuestras vidas
los humanos digitales estaban movidos
por un espíritu de generosidad de
transparencia de colaboración en el
momento que estamos viviendo hoy la
característica es la interacción de los
humanos con las máquinas máquinas que
aprenden de los humanos y que
desarrollan ese aprendizaje para mejorar
la interacción con los humanos
este momento no se está haciendo
enormemente felices a mí y a mi gato
messi me suele despertar a las 6 de la
mañana sino un poco antes bajamos a la
cocina se frota en mi brazo maúlla hasta
que le doy comida le gusta oír la radio
yo enciendo la radio y él sigue comiendo
desde hace unos cuantos meses hemos
colocado la cocina al asistente de voz
con la inteligencia artificial y mes y
yo somos felices porque a mí antes nadie
me hablaba mientras messi devoraba su
comida y ahora con el asistente de voz
yo le saludo buenos días
buenos días juan y seleccionó la emisora
de radio que quiero escuchar las
noticias que me apetece escuchar en
según qué periódico o qué medio de
comunicación le producto por el tiempo
me pregunto cuánto voy a tardar a la
próxima reunión que tengo programada y
messi es feliz porque le gusta
escucharnos mientras devora su comida
el momento en que vivimos
debo decir que lo vivo con enorme
entusiasmo
y no sólo esto sino que conforme avanza
la digitalización de nuestras vidas de
nuestra sociedad
entiendo más a los humanos digitales y
me siento ya enteramente como uno de
ellos
este momento es el del progreso
tecnológico y científico acelerado
acelerado de manera exponencial y además
es convergente lo está cambiando todo en
nuestras vidas absolutamente todo la
forma en la que trabajamos la forma en
la que aprendemos la forma en que nos
relacionamos está cambiando nuestra
forma de ser nuestra propia esencia de
humanos
lo que ocurre es que la velocidad y la
cantidad de los cambios que se están
produciendo muchas veces nos produce
vértigo estos cambios se han introducido
la inestabilidad en nuestras vidas y la
inestabilidad genera incertidumbre temor
a veces lo vemos todo es muy borroso
tenemos miedo hay que superar ese miedo
tenemos miedo porque no sabemos porque
necesitamos conocer y ver el horizonte y
tenemos miedo porque estamos
infoxicación porque
si estamos in fox y k2 lo que tenemos
que hacer es aplicar una dieta digital
seleccionar qué cómo dónde cuándo y para
qué consumimos consumimos información y
conocimiento y trasladamos la
información en conocimiento y en
inteligencia en una herramienta que nos
sirva para tomar decisiones en nuestras
vidas
no dejarnos caer en el poder del árbol
ismo
yo vivo en el humanismo tecno optimista
el humanismo tecno y mixta es una
actitud de vida es una visión es un
propósito es
una ilusión la ilusión que ha tenido
siempre el ser humano cuando ha querido
desarrollar la tecnología y la ciencia
con el propósito de vivir mucho mejor
y para que si no estaríamos empeñados en
investigar y en desarrollar tecnología
en los laboratorios no se me ocurre nada
mejor
de hecho no se me ocurre otro para que
que para construirnos un futuro mejor
la tecnología es cosa nuestra es cosa de
los humanos a veces esas fotografías
distópicas de futuros no deseables nos
llevan a la confusión nos llevan a hacer
creer que la tecnología es algo que nos
ha caído por alguna divinidad extraña
por un advenimiento y nos olvidamos que
quienes desarrollan cualquier
dispositivo cualquier red para
comunicarnos cualquier vitamina que nos
ayuda a vivir mejor es un humano
es tiempo de aventuras de experimentar
es tiempo de exploradores es tiempo de
líderes de líderes que ayuden a
comprender hacia dónde vamos y que nos
obliguen a pensar para que vamos hacia
dónde queremos ir líderes con espíritu
gtc de generosidad transparencia y
colaboración es tiempo de reaprender de
inventar de crear mucho sobre la base
del conocimiento de la innovación del
emprendimiento
vivimos una especie de nuevo
renacimiento en el que se necesitan
nuevas capacitaciones una nueva manera
de aprender una nueva forma de adquirir
conocimientos conocimientos compartidos
que gracias a la tecnología
compartimos miles de millones de
personas en cualquier lugar del mundo en
tiempo real es un futuro de enormes
oportunidades
viviremos más seremos más inteligentes y
nuestro reto es construir el súper
bienestar super longevidad su super
bienestar
pensemos en un futuro perfecto y
olvidémonos de un pasado imperfecto con
la tecnología hoy casi todo es posible
lo que no se sueña no se construye y lo
que no se empieza a construir no nunca
se alcanzará quien teme a los humanos
digitales no es a los humanos digitales
a quienes tenemos que temer es a quienes
no nos permiten soñar
[Aplausos]